الاقتراب اكثر من الوضع الانساني في
السودان ينضم الينا الاستاذ اسامه ابو بكر
المسؤول الاعلاميه للهلال الاحمر السوداني
من الخرطوم مرحبا بك يا سيد اسامه هذه
الهدنه التي تبدو وان كانت هشه هل ساعدتكم
في امكانيه اللجوء الى
مساعده او تخفيف المعاناه الانسانيه على
السودانيين هل نجحت في اقامه اي ممرات
انسانيه امنه لعملكم
نعم هذه المبادره او الهدنه ساعدت الى حد
كبير والسبب في كده انه هدلتين متصلين مع
بعض يعني مجموعهم سته ايام دلوقتي احنا
داخلين في اليوم الخامس الهدنه الثانيه
طبعا ساعدتنا وبعدين طبعا التنوعت الانشطه
بتاعت الهلال الاحمر كانت في البدايه
الاسبوع الاول من الازمه كانت قاصره نسبه
للظروف الامنيه والاشتباكات في الاحياء
كانت قاصره على دعم المستشفيات بالكوادر
المؤهله في الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه
واسعافات الاوليه وكان في شويه عمليات
اخلاء ده على مستوى ولايه الخرطوم نحن
نتكلم عن الاقاليم التانيه دلوقتي الهدنه
دي برضو ساعدت لانه ظهرت ازمه جديده في
عدد النازحين الى القرى والولايات
المجاوره للولايات الخرطوم اعداد ضخمه جدا
وعدد النازحين الى مدينه حلفا
ليعبروا الى مصر
الناس العابرين الى مدخل الموجودين في
مدينه وادي حلف الحدوديه عشان يعبروا بين
الناحيتين اللي هو المعبر الرئيسي
ومعبد اشكال طبعا دي خلفت احتياجات يعني
خلفت ازمه غذائيه كبيره جدا في المدينه
لانه المخزون عند المدينه ما كان متوقع
الاعداد الهائله دي الحمد لله اني سوداني
بامكانيات الولايه بتاعتنا المصارعه
الولايه المتواضعه كانوا بيقدموا اول حاجه
للناس اللي بيكونوا ايام مستنيين في
المعبر يدخلوا كذا قدمت دعم نفسي للاطفال
قدمت بعض الوجبات الغذائيه السريعه
والعصائر
لديكم مخزون يكفي هل مازال لديكم مخزون هل
عاونتكم اي مؤسسه من مؤسسات المجتمع
المدنيه العامله في مجال الدعم الانساني
لا في مدينه حلفا ما كان ما في منظمات
شغاله كثيره لان هي مدينه حدوديه وبعيده
لكن
تعاونا مع الهلال الاحمر المصري
الناس اللي كانوا في الحدود في المعبر في
الجانب السوداني كان الهلال الاحمر
السوداني
كلهم لانه عدد كبير جدا من الناس لكن
فهمنا في تقليل مياه شرب دي كانت مساله
مهمه جدا وبعض الاغذيه والعصائر
وبعض اخلاء بعض المصابين من الاعياء من
كبار السن للمراكز الصحيه الموجوده هناك
والطرق الاسعافات الاوليه برضه في الولايه
الشماليه ساعدت في يعني انقاص حالات كثيره
جدا بالاسعافات الاوليه البسيطه يعني كان
ممكن يحصل لهم اعياء وارهاق
في الجانب المصري الهلال الاحمر المصري ما
شاء الله عليه قام بدور ممتاز جدا برضو في
مساعده الناس وتقديم الوجبات اللي هم
والدعم النفسي للاطفال وكده لان الاطفال
كان الوضع الاصل هم فيه يعني في قلب
العاصمه الخرطوم كان هناك وضع انساني صعب
للغايه نقص في الاغذيه اصابات وبعضها خطير
المستشفيات تحتاج الى دعم كبير هل نجحتم
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه من عقد
الهدنه في دعم هذا المسار ايضا
نعم نعم يعني اول حاجه فرق الهلال الاحمر
من المطوعين ونحييهم من هنا المتطوعين دول
يعني
ما طبيعي ومن مالهم الخاص احيانا
يلا المطوعين في المدن
من الخرطوم
مدينه حلفا اللي هم النازحين في ناس نجحوا
للقرى المجاوره شمال الخرطوم وكده فكانت
متطوعين لنا من ولايه نهر النيل ومطوعيننا
من الشماليه كانوا في المواطن بتاعه
الباصات
والحافلات برضو بيقدموا معونه للناس هو
معونه بالعصائر والمياه وكده
الان يمكن من خلاله ان تدخل المؤسسات
الدوليه لانك تعلم ان الامم المتحده كانت
تقول ان الوضع غير امن وبالتالي لا نستطيع
انزال الفرق لتحسين الوضع الانساني هل
الان على الهواء يمكن ان تقيم بان الوضع
اصبح امن شبه امن يسمح بدخول المؤسسات
الدوليه ومنها الامم المتحده بالطبع
وطبعا الوضع دلوقتي اخفى يعني اليومين
اللي فاتوا امبارح والليله اكثر اماما
اماما مش في احياء الخطوط طبعا حاليا في
احياء الخرطوم الولايه الكبرى في
حالات بتاعه العنفذ جدا واشتباكات في
مناطق معينه في ام درمان وفي خرطوم بحري
ومواجهات لكن بالنسبه للامم المتحده وحتى
المنظمات العالميه الثانيه عشان تجيب
مساعدات انسانيه وصحيه وطبيه وغذائيه
لتاتي عن طريق المطارات وال
تحدي مطار في مطار في
القاعده
ايضا تم ايقاف العمل به لاعتبارات امنيه
بالضبط كده لانه بيعتبر يعني هدف عسكري
بالنسبه للخصم يعني وبالتالي
نفس المساله موجوده انه عشان يجيبوا
مساعدات
نعم استاذ اسامه ابو بكر المسؤول
الاعلاميه للهلال الاحمر السوداني من
الخرطوم تحياتي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات